26 years after his son was killed by Pro
British paramilitaries Raymond McCord's
pursuit of justice is now focused on the
government in London British government
are trying to ensure that they'll never
be able to grave and many people like me
it's not going to happen we we'll beat
them in
court the Northern Ireland troubles act
prevents new investigations and offers
conditional immunity for crimes
committed during three decades of
conflict Westminster says it's intended
to promote reconciliation victims groups
say it's a breach of their human rights
this is to protect security agencies of
the British State and I'm a unionist
person and I have no problem whatsoever
saying
that the government hor are covered in
blood in the Catholic suburbs of
Londoner another family still Mourns
15-year-old Daniel hegy was gunned down
by a British soldier during operations
to reclaim so-called no go areas there
in
1972 well the enquir found that danger
posed no
threat and he was shot at six feet twice
in the head by a British soldier by a
British soldier Daniel's Sister Margaret
believes the Legacy law is a further
attempt to Shield British soldiers from
prosecution while denying victims the
right to justice but they're forcing
that law on us the people who don't want
it are being told you're going to do
what we tell you that's wrong estimates
vary but it's thought that more than a
thousand troubles era killings remain
unsolved something the so-called Legacy
law is meant to help draw a line under
but it's been met with near Universal
condemnation by all parties and both
main communities in an often still
divided Northern
Ireland even military veterans groups
who long campaigned for soldiers to be
protected from prosecution are skeptical
Ken Johnston was a spokesman for the
British army during the troubles we w
certainly across the veteran Community
they were trained for defense of
democracy and choice and they will take
that training with them and quietly get
on with
it and I think that's the picture in
Northern irand so yes there's opposition
but don't take it as card blanch one
size does not fit all in Northern
Ireland it never will jahal Al jazer
Belfast make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer